now it's time for this day in history
this day in history on this day in
history in 1820 King George the third
died
you will remember King George the third
from when we worked his greatest
military force in the world during the
Revolutionary War in one a country for
ourselves because of this unhappy
connection Americans sometimes take a
glib and dismissive view of George the
third his 4000 pound statue in downtown
Manhattan became the first casualty in
America's increasing obsession with
toppling monuments the mob did have a
good reason in that case though after
the Declaration of Independence was read
for the first time publicly in New York
on July 9 1776 a group of future
soldiers stormed downtown to melt the
statue for bullets that's fair enough
that's a that's a decent use by the
outbreak of the war George the third had
not even received the Declaration of
Independence on the question of various
burdens to pay for the French and Indian
War like the stamp tax George the third
was generally more sympathetic than his
government to the colonists concerns the
tax burdens on the colonists were far
lower than those imposed on George's
subjects in Britain indeed though they
were the lowest in the Western world the
taxes imposed on the American colonists
George was generally fairly Universalist
in his charity of one of the complaints
actually that our founding fathers
listed in the Declaration of
Independence is that the king had
defended the rights of quote merciless
Indian savages he was too nice to the
Indians after the Revolutionary War King
George the third was very frank about
this you know that this is a guy who had
a great character and reputation in in
Britain he I believe he was shockingly
loyal and faithful to his wife he may
have been the only royal ever in history
to be faithful to his wife this was a
guy of good classical education good
morality and after the war he said quote
I will be very frank with you I was the
last to consent to the separation but
the separation having been made and
having become inevitable I had always
said as I say now that I would be the
first to meet the friendship of the
United States as an independent power he
didn't want to lose the Americas in the
United
dates but having lost them he meant him
them as gentlemen and a separate
independent powers when Benjamin West
George's royal court painter and a good
old Pennsylvania boy told King George
the 3rd that George Washington would
step down as leader of the United States
after two terms
George responded if he does that he will
be the greatest man in the world so
while we find ourselves battling the
statue toddlers who want to tear down
and erase our history all of the great
men who built our country perhaps we
should be an example and take an even
broader and more charitable view and
give even former foes like George the
third their due so r.i.p George the
third a good good king we had our
differences we fought a war over it and
now he's a good guy we should look back
on him with some dignity